it's a time of great transition in the
world economy and it's crucial that
important causes and problems are not
forgotten this January a diverse world
leaders will be discussing how we
redesign and rethink many aspects of our
world youtube and the World Economic
Forum are often in one person the
opportunity to join them we need big
thinkers people who in stand up and get
their voices heard we are opening the
doors to Davos to someone passionate and
articulate fighting for something that
deserves everyone's attention what issue
do you believe needs rethinking how
would you redesign our approach to
pressing problems if you could reveal
your cause how could those are divers
help and inspire you we want to hear
real stories from people working on
local causes who want to make these
causes global maybe its human rights or
the environment or poverty or
discrimination maybe your coffees
education political freedom or saving
the world's oceans are you ready to
stand up on the devil stage alongside
some of the most influential people in
the world and fight for your cause
pressed record make your page upload it
to YouTube then submit your video to
youtube.com slash dollars before the 4th
of January 2010 for your chance to be
part of the Davos debates